hi in this video I would like to talk
about macrophages macrophages are one of
the very important immune cells so these
immune cells are abridging immune cells
between innate and adaptive immune
system so before knowing their mechanism
of action and how this saves our body
and what are the functions of
macrophages in our body we would like to
talk about how the macrophages are
formed inside our body so here is a bone
and if we take a cross section of this
bone we would find here the industrial
niche and a vascular niche so vascular
niche is actually associated with the
blood vessels inside the bones and the
industrial niche is basically the
forming the bone marrow and if we
simplify the diagram so inside this
diagram we can see that here is inside
the bone marrow inside the bone in the
bone marrow we have hematopoietic
pluripotent stem cell HSC so from the
hematopoietic pluripotent stem cell we
have two type of progenitors one is
lymphoid progenitor and one is myeloid
progenitor cell so from the myeloid
progenitor cell we have monocyte and
this monocyte would ultimately give rise
to macrophages and from this lymphoid
progenitor cell we would get the
adaptive immune system cells that means
the T cell and the b-cells so here at
the monocyte which is ultimately derived
from the myeloid progenitor cell would
enter the blood stream that means from
the industrial niche it would migrate to
the vascular niche and inside the wash
from in the vascular niche it would
migrate further and it would might and
eventually it would come to the tissue
space and in the tissue space this
monocyte would get converted into
macrophages and let's see it in a detail
so here we have the cross section of our
skin so inside our scheme here is the
epidermis here are the carrots nice eyes
and here is a darkness and beneath the
darkness
we have circulating the Bloods
circulation the blood vessels and inside
blood vessels
we have circulating monocytes so let's
see what happens so when there is a
injury by a nail and this is a rusty
nail so there is a lot of pathogen
associated with it when the bathurst
pathogen invades our body the first
surveillance cells are macrophages so
these macrophages would come and detect
this pathogen and this detection is done
by a special kind of receptors which I
would discuss in a moment and they would
detect the pathogen and they would alarm
the whole body that there is an invasion
by a pathogen and they would alarm the
other divisions of immune system about
the invasion and what happens when there
is a pathogen invasion more and more
monocytes get inside the tissue space
and become macrophages so here is a
circulating molar site so it would stop
circulating and it would pass through
these pores of the blood vessels and it
would enter the tissue space and in the
tissue space it would change and it
would evolve into a macrophage and the
macrophage can recognize the pathogen
and encounter the pathogen so our
macrophage is just like a police officer
a patrolling police officer because like
a petulant police officer a macrophage
virtually here and there and looking for
any type of crime or any type of
invasion so when a patrolling police
officer finds there is an invasion by a
thief or a goon he would inform others
of the other polices of the department
and similarly when macrophage finds one
pathogen when macrophage interacts one
pathogen it would alarm other
macrophages all around the body to come
there and fight against the pathogen
also macrophage would alarm the other
divisions like the army divisions of our
body that are the t-cells and b-cells
so that they could fight the pathogen
efficiently and clear those pathogen so
in that respect macrophage is essential
so macrophage is just like a patrolling
police officer so now we will take a
look how macrophages actually recognized
pathogen so inside macrophages there are
many type of receptors called toll-like
receptors so using these toll-like
receptors they can identify some trails
of the pathogen which they would find
suspicious and by looking at these
trails they can understand which type of
pathogen it is and these toll likes
receptors mediated signal would
ultimately generate the alarming model
molecules that would inform other cells
of the body and other macrophages to
come and fight the pathogen in other
respect this macrophage is professional
antigen presenting cell because it has
class 2 MHC and why they are called
antigen presenting cell I would discuss
it in another video and for the
mechanism of killing of pathogen by
macrophages we would focus on the
pathways so for pathogen killing
mechanism macrophage evolved to
particular mechanism one is oxygen
dependent killing and another is oxygen
independent killing so once there is a
pathogen invasion the macrophage would
engulf the pathogen so inside the
macrophage so inside the macrophage
there is a vesicle and lysosome would
fuse with those vesicles and deliver the
hydrolytic enzymes to clear the pathogen
an other method is reactive oxygen
species and reactive nitrogen species
can cause harm to the pathogen and thus
killing the packagin so there are two
mechanisms used by the macrophages now
we would focus on the mechanism which is
oxygen dependent that means reactive
oxygen species and
reactive nitrogen species dependent
mechanism so in the reactive oxygen so
this reactive oxygen species are
generated when macrophage in girls a
pathogen it in also involves a lot of
oxygen along with it and this oxygen is
converted to superoxide radicals by
NADPH phagosome oxidase so inside the
phagosome of the macrophage so here here
are the phagosome of macrophage so
inside the phagosome of the macrophage
the oxygen is actually converted into
superoxide radical and this superoxide
radical is a reactive oxygen oxygen
species not only superoxide radical
other as reactive oxygen species like
h2o 2 and my lab and HCL o which is
formed by myeloperoxidase can also
damage the pathogen apart from that
there is a einar's pathway that is
inducible nitric oxide synthetase
and these Inox ultimately give rise to
or oxynitride which is a reactive oxygen
species reactive nitrogen species these
reactive oxygen species or reactive
nitrogen species could cause damage in
the pathogen it could cause changes in
the membrane composition and when the
membrane composition is changed so there
is a change in Asamoah lytic balance in
the pathogen and the pathogen would
ultimately keep lized
because there is a osmotic dis balance
so ultimately this and ultimately the
macrophage is able to kill the pathogen
and sometimes it's not possible for the
macrophage to kill the pathogen so
macrophage secrete some molecules like
interleukin 1 which are inflammation
producing molecules these molecules
alarm other macrophages around the body
and other immune cells to come and fight
the pathogen and that's conclude the
video on macrophage I hope you enjoyed
this video I hope this video was helpful
to you if you like my video give it
thumbs up don't forget to subscribe and
please leave your comments below thank
you